MAN: You're trapped.
I wouldn't mind having
toad legs tonight.
But I'm not sure
if I can eat him.
What I do notice is all
these orange little vessels
popping up on his stomach.
And I know sometimes that means
it's poisonous to the animals
that eat it.
But the animals that
eat it don't cook it.
So.
I don't know.
Man.
Since I can't confirm whether or
not the toads are safe to eat,
little guy is free.
Better safe than sorry always.
I'm thinking about hunting
anything and everything I can.
If you have an opportunity
to get some valuable meat,
you have to seize it.
So every morning,
I hear these ducks
landing here on this bend.
They float down the
river a little bit,
flapping their wings,
making all this commotion.
And so, trying to figure out
a way to get one of those.
But I can't just shoot
my arrows into the water.
What I'm going to
try and do is I'm
going to attach some
paracord to my arrow
and see if I can
shoot and retrieve it.
Instead of using the
whole heavy paracord,
and pull out all these
inner filaments and tie them
end to end will be much lighter.
I think I might have the least
practical knowledge of anybody
here.
These aren't things that I've
been practicing all my life,
or even things I've
gone to school for.
I'm kind of like an
ad hoc survivalist.
I have an idea.
I see something that
needs to be done.
And then I try and
fabricate a means to do it.
All right.
So there it is.
I've laid all my
line out, and then
brought it all the way back and
secured it to my leg, you know,
to anchor it obviously.
Going to take this
down to the water.
I'll give it a try.
I haven't eaten
anything yet today.
I'm hungry, but I'm worried
that I missed my window.
They usually land up there,
float all the way down here.
And they've done that
two or three times a day
and nothing now.
So I've got all
my line laid out.
Just going to sit here and wait.
I know there's supposed to be a
lot of grouse and other ground
birds around here.
Some tarmigan.
So I'm hoping to
spot some of them.
My plan is to set some traps.
I know that there are all
types of weasels and badgers
that run around here.
So my game is to stand
out as many as I can
and hopefully get
something to bite.
Oh [bleep].
at this.
Freaking deer floating
down the river.
Got to get it, I got to
get it, I got to get it.
Oh, I see you.
You're still sitting there.
You're stuck.
You can't hide.
[bleep] Skimmed its back.
You're sitting like a
freaking deer target.
I can do this.
Right over his neck.
[bleep] It's taking off.
Damn.
It's heartbreaking that I wasn't
able to bring down that deer.
Could have smoked it all.
I could have made that
deer last a month.
You know, so it just
leads me now to have to,
you know, I've
decided that I need
to tap deeper into my
resolve and determination.
I've emerged with a new idea.
Just a new method of
going about things.
Every time I catch a fish, I'm
using the entrails for traps.
Every time I go for
walks, I'm setting snares.
I go for too many
walks and I don't
do these things when I'm
passing all the areas
that I should be doing them.
And me getting that free meal
that just left me so easily
leads me to believe that I
need to be out here doing
a whole lot more.
I need to conquer the land a
little bit more than I have.
I've been slowly traversing it.
I need to be stomping
it and taking it over.
So that's what I'm going to do.
He agrees.